- Good afternoon.
Come on guys, good afternoon.
- [Audience] Good afternoon.
- Yeah, very happy to be
here with my good friend,
Nitesh Ambastha.
And we are going to be talking
about modernizing wealth
management using cloud and AI.
Now, wealth management is
a very interesting space
within financial services,
highly profitable,
but from a technology perspective,
I think it's fair to say,
has been a bit of a laggard.
And that's, I think, an opportunity
because with all the
changes happening with cloud
and now AI, there is a real
opportunity to leapfrog
and what better, who better
to talk about it than Nitesh?
Nitesh is a industry leader,
senior leader at LPL Financial
and I know that he is,
this is something he's
very passionate about.
So Nitesh, we'll do it in three parts.
- Okay.
- So,
see, it's about strategy to
execution, it's about impact.
So we'll cover the spectrum.
We'll start with maybe laying out
what is the opportunity here.
- Yeah
- We'll start with that.
We'll then get to the but part of it,
you know, so, you know, that
what are some of the challenges
and then we'll get to to solutions,
all in the next 15 minutes.
- Awesome.
- Okay?
- Yeah, let's go for it.
- Without further ado,
let's start with the opportunity.
The hero of the story for wealth
managers are our advisors.
- Yeah.
- And everybody is trying
to make the experience
better for advisors.
There has been this promise
about advisor personalization,
not fully delivered,
but with AI, how do you
see this playing out?
You know, how could you know
AI transform the experience
and the proposition for advisors?
- Yeah, thank you.
Thanks for that question.
I think all of us are trying
to figure that one out.
You know, personalization is very easy
if you have only one client
and if they don't change their mind ever,
then it's super easy.
But the hard part with
personalization has been
that it's an ecosystem, it's a system.
It's not a feature or a product, right?
It's a system.
And systems are messy.
And the reason systems are messy is
because clients are messy
and not in a humorous way.
- And Nitesh is a client of mine.
- Yes.
So you know that from experience,
I made everybody wait while I
was running through the expo.
So yeah, clients are messy,
they change their mind,
they have their preferences
changing and so on.
And so personalization
has been a challenge
and it continues to be a challenge.
The part about personalization
has always been
that let's say you are an advisor
and all these are your clients.
If you try to personalize it for everyone,
let's say you do it,
everyone will have unique demands off you.
And that is hard for an
advisor to keep up with.
And so where AI comes in is
it takes the heavy lifting
from advisor's plate.
Today, I think advisors spend 60 to 70%
of their time preparing for
meetings, collecting documents,
and lot of stuff
that they are not spending
time with clients.
And so that 60, 70% is
your attack space with AI.
If you can get to that
and then advisors can focus
their time with customers
and they can use their
relationships better,
that's the holy grail.
And so we'll see how
far we can get to that.
But I think AI has all those promises.
With agentic AI, we can
automate a lot of that work
that advisors are doing manually today
or they have to spend their time doing.
- So that's very exciting
that AI can take, you know,
do a lot of the heavy lifting, you know,
behind personalization.
Now let's get to the big,
the bigger picture that,
what does that imply from a
business model perspective
and maybe even putting the
LPL hat on that, you know,
where you play in the value chain
and you know, everybody's trying to,
you know, in wealth management, you know,
trying to be this financial
kind of supermarket.
So how could AI be bit of a disruptor
and maybe help you leapfrog?
Is that a possibility?
- Yeah, definitely for
LPL, it's a possibility.
Like we were not advanced
in a lot of products
and feature capabilities like warehouses.
And LPL having 30,000 advisors
affecting the financial wellbeing
of about 8 million clients,
can definitely be that
marketplace ecosystem.
And you mentioned the word leapfrog.
We do have that opportunity.
We don't have to go
through traditional models
of building a banking lending product
or traditional ways of
creating sec lending desk.
You can go straight to
agentic and AI based model.
You can skip a generation, as LPL,
go straight to those opportunities that,
let's say existing players
will take a long time
to change their model.
We don't have anything,
so we can go straight to
the target segment there.
So that's an opportunity segment,
opportunity space for us.
How does that translate is,
you know, we have our own
margin expansion targets
and you and me were talking about
like boards are excited about it,
all the management teams
is excited about it.
So the trick is to really
figure out those use cases.
You can't stop the hype, right?
If you try to fight the
hype curve, you will lose.
So you have to pick and choose those areas
where you can actually make a difference.
AI clearly is very good
at natural language text,
all of that use cases.
And so you would want
to deploy it there first
and get some value and
then it becomes a flywheel.
And so that's kind of the direction
of travel we are after with AI at LPL.
We definitely believe that
we can leapfrog a generation
and come, close the gap with warehouses
in terms of capabilities
and features much faster.
- So that's very exciting.
And you know, you talked
about customer experience,
you talked about business model
and that eventually
implies revenue and growth.
Let's talk about the
third big business KPI
which is cost, cost to serve.
- Yeah.
- And you did mention
margin, you know, earlier
that cost to serve has
also been a bit sticky
in this industry.
So how do you see AI really making a
difference to the cost to serve?
- No, that's actually an opportunity area
where we can attack first.
And cost to serve has been
on our radar for a while
and we have tried to
make incremental progress
in that space.
But what is now possible is you can look
at those end-to-end workflow
steps in the cost to serve.
Like whether it is
account opening workflows
or commission processing workflows
or simple money movement,
how fast you can do those things.
Today, there are a lot of exception cases
or even supervision use cases.
There are so many human beings involved
in an account opening, account
transfer kind of use cases.
And those are ripe areas
where you can say, okay,
we can look at this as a
completely inside out approach
instead of incrementally
making those workflows better,
right? You don't have to do
the typical workflow systems
like our favorite workflow
products from the past.
- Right.
- And say, hey, let's look at
this completely differently.
And until I saw a demo of this live,
I couldn't believe where an advisor
or end user is trying to chat
to create an account opening
or KYC AML kind of use case.
And on the side you can see
what the agents are doing
and that experience is fully
personalized to that advisor.
So each advisor office
can do this differently
and they have a very
personalized experience
on how they open accounts,
how they deal with clients
and all, how they lift
that margin up for them.
And that results into us
having a significant boost
in our margin targets.
And so that's the first area
in 2026 we are going to go after,
which is starting with the
operational transformation area
and then learn from that
and go after other business clients.
- And it's fascinating that,
you know, as you're
talking about operations,
that this is not just about cost,
but this is also about personalization
and improving the customer experience.
So fascinating set of possibilities,
almost feels like being
a child in a toy shop,
there is so much you can do.
- Yeah.
- But there's also a reality check
that I think it's fair to say, Nitesh
and I know that you're very aware of it,
that there is a chasm between
the promise and the reality.
- Yeah.
- So what are some of
the challenges that you
and your teams are seeing
in terms of implementing AI
and cloud and realizing this vision?
- Yeah, like there are a
couple of stats I'll give you.
One is the number of AI use cases truly
in production according to
McKinsey survey was about 6, 7%.
So we should be aware of that.
The second stat is getting
to a 60 to 70% accurate model
and result is very fast.
But from there, trying to get
to 80%, 90% is extremely hard.
And so knowing that it's,
those things are hard,
you solve for, to answer your question,
the difficult problems first,
which is something, you know,
my team keeps reminding me.
I always say solve for the
difficult problems first.
And that is creating a data ecosystem
which is conducive to this, right?
So, at LPL we have been on
this journey of transforming
with your team's help, Incedo team's help,
we have been on this journey, you know,
on transforming from a monolith
to a data product environment
where you can have a modern fabric
and it's event driven where
you can now connect data
that we have on platform
versus off platform data.
And now you can do those use cases faster.
So that is a hard yard
fixing the data ecosystem,
getting it ready, but that's
in itself is not enough.
In a financial services firm,
you have to think about security,
you need to think about
trust in the ecosystem
because our business is all about trust.
Our clients trust our advisors,
and that's how they are in business.
So we are have to be
extremely prepared for trust
and security.
Now, we all know that this
whole technology landscape
is very new, two and a half
years old, three years old.
And so the maturity of
that is not there yet.
So you want to start in an area
where you feel strong, comfortable with
and not like a most important
segment of your business,
you put AI through.
So I would say those two.
And the third one, which is
obvious to all the people here,
is about talent, right?
You have to do a talent transformation.
It's not just, you know,
like I would take an
example of my own team.
I see leaders who are
actually embracing AI
and they're doing it themselves.
Like, and then there are leaders
who are telling their teams
to do it, but they're
not themselves doing it.
And you know, when I self-reflect,
I was one of those second type of leaders.
So I've just enrolled in a course myself
so I can do it myself.
But talent transformation is very good.
- And let's double click
on a couple of these.
You know, there are three
or four important issues
that you have raised, Nitesh.
Let's talk about data.
- Yeah.
- Because you know, you also talked about,
you know, choosing the right sequence
and data is very tricky
because, you know, data
is, can be like everything
and very hard to kind of work through.
And in your case, you've
had the added complexity
or challenge that you have been kind
of doing a spate of M&As, you
know, at least one every year.
- Yeah.
- And what I've found
very interesting is that,
you have used that,
that has been a challenge
from a data perspective,
but you have used that as an opportunity
to actually upgrade your
kind of data foundation.
So talk us through that a bit,
that how have you approached
this whole data journey?
And especially with this, you know,
the whole focus on inorganic growth?
- Yeah, no, I think
that has helped us a lot
because many places when firms try
to upgrade their data ecosystem,
the challenge is your main
business runs on legacy
and now you want to build something
or transform through something new.
But how do you, you know,
motivate or change that
much of current ecosystem,
that applications, advisor, workstation,
all of that to go to the new platform?
So we use M&A as an opportunity,
think of it as a beachhead approach.
So when we were integrating
with our largest client till date,
Credential Financial,
we introduced a new broker dealer concept,
introducing broker dealer.
And that didn't exist at LPL.
So we got that as an opportunity
to put that data flow,
all the ecosystem around
credential integration
onto data foundation,
which is the new AWS based,
cloud-based modernized
platform that we are building.
And then as we did the next M&A
which is, you know, we
acquired Atria Wealth,
we put all the TAMP flows,
which are new to LPL,
what we used to do was
very small tiny footprint,
whereas Atria got us an
opportunity where it was all TAMPs.
And so we took all that flow
and put that on data foundation.
But we didn't, so we
continue that journey in 2026
where we have announced the acquisition
of Commonwealth Financial
and Commonwealth,
we are going to do the big piece now
where all of our custody
data will be moving
on to data foundation.
So this is the real big milestone.
So we've used those opportunities
to transform our journey.
It does comes with the complexity
of keeping the two systems,
two sets of ecosystem in sync.
That's where your teams come
in and help us from Incedo.
So thanks for your partnership
there, but it's complex.
That's the hardier you need to do
before we could be ready
for the AI journey.
But we are very glad that we did all
that work over the last two, three years.
So we are ready for the next phase.
- You know, I wanna go
back to the point you made
about sequence.
I think that's a very important thing
that how do you skin the cat?
So share some tips with us
that how do you choose the
right things to do, you know,
what may seem like the biggest
may not be what you focus on.
I know that that's something
you think a lot about.
- Yeah.
- So give us some tips around that.
- I think, you know, that's
the, if I have to give one tip,
it is really the sequencing.
It's not so much about can you come up
with the best architecture, right?
Or what's the best
architecture for agentic AI
and, you know, what technology
tool products we should buy,
that's not going to get you there.
It's really doing things
in the right sequence.
And the fundamental part,
or the most important thing
for us from a sequencing perspective
that we have learned is the
journey to data foundation
and journey to cloud.
Without those ingredients,
you cannot even start.
And so since we have done,
or we on our journey to
get those two things done,
now comes the, how do you
democratize access to data
and AI tools to a broader ecosystem.
So right now, while we are
experimenting with use cases,
the thing that we are trying to solve for
is how our business lines get engaged,
how the product teams get engaged,
how is it democratized for
everyone to start working with AI
at a pace.
Otherwise they, if all of
them wait for technology
and product to give them tools,
then we'll be behind the game.
So that's the next one that,
which is learning journey
for the organization
and building that momentum,
which is what we are up.
And the third thing, which
I said is the security
and the trust in the solution we've built.
That, those three things in the sequence
and then you can go after,
you know, what is the
best technology out there
and what should we, whom
should we partner with?
- I, on the clock here, I'll
come to my last question,
which is about talent.
You know, in the AI age,
paradoxically the human
aspect becomes more important.
So finally, people, talent.
- Yeah.
- You know, what are
your top three kind of,
you know, mantras or, you know,
what are, what is the different
that you're expecting from your teams?
I know a lot of your
teammates are sitting here,
so very important for them.
- Yeah. I think, you know,
anecdotally what I heard is
we are the last generation
who are managing only human beings.
After this,
our next generations will
be managing human beings
and AI agents.
I don't know if it'll be true,
but that's the promised land.
I think it's not something
magical is what I would say,
but it's something you embrace, right?
It's no longer like, okay,
can I stay on the sidelines approach?
So it's happening and as I said,
I'm taking it on myself to learn.
Some of my team members
are already experimenting
and doing the coding themselves.
And it's become so easy
that you don't have
to be a programmer anymore.
So I think it's about everyone trying
to do it themselves is the mantra.
And you know, the hiring
will change in future more
towards ML engineering
will become the main thing
as opposed to software
engineering or Python
or what used to be, you
know, full stack engineer.
So the twist will be more towards,
like all our hirings will shift
towards ML engineering skillset.
- Amazing. I have a, you
know, we are at time,
Gautam is looking at me.
So, Nitesh Ambastha, thank you so much.
- Well thank you.
- You know, 18 minutes.
We managed to cover the entire value chain
of modernizing wealth
management with cloud and AI.
You know, appreciate your insights
and thank you to all the audience.
Thank you also to AWS
to bring us together here. Thank you.
- Thank you.